في البحث عن اسرار امنيه تقبع في قاع
البحر الاسود تحاول موسكو ان تستعيد حطام
المسيره الامريكيه من طراز
اسابيع من البحث والملايين من الدولارات
قد تتكبدها موسكو لاستعاده حطام المسيره
التي ارتطمت بطائرتين روسيتين عدا عن ان
الحطام منتشر بشكل كبير تجرفه التيارات
بشكل متناثر على مساحه واسعه بحسب الخبراء
عدا عن العمق الهائل فالمسيره غارقه على
عمق اكثر من 4000 الى 5000 قدم بحسب
البنتاجون لتحتاج موسكو الى معدات معقده
وروبوتات تحت المياه والتي غالبا تستخدم
في قطاع النفط والغاز البحري
من المحتمل ان يرسلوا غواصات صغيره لتحديد
موقع البقايا وربطها ورفعها الى السطح
الولايات المتحده رجحت ان روسيا وصلت
بالفعل الى اجزاء صغيره من المسيره الا
انها ايضا قللت من اهميه الوصول الى
الحطام لتقوم الجهات المسؤوله بمحو
البرنامج الحساس للمسيره بعض سقوطها في
البحر
جعلنا من المستحيل عليهم جمع اي شيء ذي
قمه استخباراتيه من بقايا تلك الطائره
مهما كانت البقايا الموجوده
عمليه انتشال معقده الا انها لن تصعب على
موسكو التي لها تاريخ في عمليات مماثله
استطعت فيها الوصول الى بقايا غواصات
وطائرات في اطار حربها الخفيه مع الولايات
المتحده اذا عمر العربيه